[Music]  I'm Paul Scheer and it's time for Ted  [Music]  thank you thank you  paradigm-shifting is suffused by  crowd-sourced micro funding and that is  why I'm here today for you to tell me  what that means I read it in one of  these bathrooms here and I didn't  understand it in my dreams I'm a  millionaire and I live an amazing life  live the life you want when you're not  awake and we don't want honey how many  times have I said it honey is not an  appropriate dipping sauce for chicken  fingers we all know that anyone  understand that because that doesn't  make any sense to me I'm really like it  pisses me off I don't get it he's not do  I smell something  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]